いくのですね
13年前
一解剖学の勉強をしてたんですねなんて今日皆さんの顔見てるとすごく懐かしいんです
けど今だにやってるかっていうと
簡単に言うと魚やんなんですね
a
なので機械工学を勉強して皆さんの魚屋
全然関係ねえじゃないかっていう思い出しかないでいただいてもしかしたら関係するか
もしれないと言う
観点で聴いていただけるとありがたいです
今日はですね皆さんに異業種で
チャレンジするときの
その取り組み方それを実行することの重要性というのを伝えしていきたいなと思ってい
ます
私はですね以前を全く別の業界に入ったんですけれども
その時に岩手に出張する機会があったんですね
その時ある亮さんとお会いさせていただきました
その量産そのお話を聞いて
私は水産業の産地においての実情というの一部を知ることができたなぁと思っています
それはですね
さんまが例えば1 k 10円とか30円で買い叩かれてるんだよって話を聞いたり
魚室も儲からないから子供にはもうつかせないことを決めているんだということを
その方はおっしゃっていました私もても通すの水産に対して何か問題意識を持っていた
かというと全然そんなことなくて
普通にまさかの食べるぐらいだったんですけどスーパーに行ったら
魚っていつでも買えるし当たり前のように存在している
そういうものだと思っていましたでも実はその当たり前っていうのが生産者の方
漁師の方の大変な苦労の上に成り立っているものだということをその時初めて気付いた
形になります
もしかしたらですね自分の子供とか
孫の世代になったときに
自分が食べているようなおいしい魚だったり刺身だったり寿司だったりそういうものが
食べられなくなるんじゃないかなというのを持ったんですね
簡単に言うと担い手がいなくなるっていう話です
その時初めて私は自分ごととして水産業を見つめ直すことができたと思います
そっから私は愛とあらゆる情報を集められる手段に関してはすべてを活用して情報を
集めていて
業界構造まず理解していこうということを務めました
ただ外部から調べですするだけですとなかなか
相矛盾した情報が共存していてよく分からないんですね
例えば惨事で言うと魚って安いよねって皆さん言うんですけど
消費地で言うと魚高くなってるよね一体何なんだということがよくわからないという
ことで
もう実際に水産関係の方に直接アイヌでどんなことが起きているのかというのを知りに
行ってきました
当然十分ではないんですけれども
業界のことを構造その時点でできる限り
理解をしてそしてそれに取り組むためのミッションとビジョンを詰めて
会社を昨年の4月に立ち上げました
その会社でやっていることっていうのはですね it を活用して水産の頭の
プラットフォームを再構築するということをいきます
とっても難しいので簡単にいうと
産地の方に得では
適正な衝撃が得られるようなプラットフォームであって僕たちはもっと美味しい魚を
なくと便利
使いやすく食べられるような世界を実現していかなきゃいけないんじゃないかなという
ことを会社としてやろうとくっています
ただ
会社としてですね
なむしろすん産業界というのは全く急騰したこと前業界なんですね
その業界にチャレンジするときに重要なのは3つあっていっしょん
1ションっていうのはこの仕事をやる理由ですね僕たちはなんでこの章であるのがそう
いうミッションができません
フォームでそれに時間軸を入れてその時間でどの状態までこの業界を持っていきたいの
か
プロビジョンとして決めます
そして実行ですねとりあえずやってみることをこのミッションとビジョンと実行
とりあえずやってみるこの3つのパッケージが五行詩にチャレンジしていくときに学び
を得ながら
立ち上げるそれをやるときに重要な要素かなと思っています
今日はとりあえずやってみるということにフォーカスしてお話を進めていきたいと思っ
ています
会社設立して1年半経ってますけど未だに学ぶことはとっても多くて実行することの
効用っていうのはすごく感じながら今会社をやっています
設立当時からで考えるととりあえず実行してみることで
新たな学びがビジネスをしながら得られると開いたの学びをやることで次のアクション
につながってい
次のオプションを突く繰り返していくことで仲間がどんどん増えていって
今度は外で応援する方がどんどん増えてきて
応援する方が大行燈をどんどん広げてくださるような良い循環が生まれ始める
そのスタートにあるがとりあえず実行しているということかなと思い
とりあえず実行してみた事例を3つくらいをご紹介させていただきたいと思います
昨年の10月くらいから
私たちは飲食店に魚をるっていう事を始めました
言葉を選ばずに言うととりあえずなんですけどとりあえず実行しました
とりあえずこうしていくときにとっても重要なことが一つあってそれをお客様に正確に
伝えることなんですね
今はやばいはこういう状態ですと
なので
我々の記念鈴木軒目のお客様にはこの説明をしました
正直今私は魚のことをよく分かってないん
だから教えてくださいその上でお取引してください
そんな話をしてました
今村とですね恋愛下手な男性が告白するようなことをやったかなと思うんですけど
それでよく付き合ってくれたなと思います
この飲食店の方ですね両町からすれば魚わからない人に一からですねさからの提案を
受けて
そしてその魚かいい
魚のことを教えそして魚についてですよ
普通するというあってはならないことが起きていたと思ういうことかなと思うんです
けど実際それがですね
実在して言ってこうやってお客様が食器私たち育ててくださったんですね
のしそれを十分な知識がないからもうちょっと勉強しお魚のことをもうちょっと勉強し
てからにしよう
料理をもっと知らなきゃいけないそれを準備してから行ってたとしたらそのスタートは
おそらく切れてなかったですし今もう至れないんじゃないかなと思いますそんな
スタートを切った
飲食店向けの魚をグルーサービスなんですけど今でいうと東京都内でだいたい1000
店舗くらいの方にあ
1000店舗くらいの飲食店に使っていただくぐらいまで成長することができました
実際そういうことが起こるわけですね
エンドユーザーの方に魚を売るというサービスもやりました
これはあの私の子供なんですけどどんなサービスかというと丸の魚がこんなでかいやつ
が賛美から5尾くらい
合計5キロ具合が毎月につき1回届くというかなり膨大な覧くださいですな
ですけどこれはですね結論から言うとを a
すっごいマニアの魚が大好きな彼
使っていただいているとあと私の親族
a 私の友人
過去の恩師に使って頂き支えていない中サービスです
なので結論から言うとですね
まだの魚はやっぱりさばけないさばけないんですねまぁこれは想定されてたんですけど
実際どれぐらいさばけないかというと
こんなことが象徴される話があるんですけど
電話があってですねそもそも伍長はないんですけどすればいいのかっていう話がある
ぐらいだね
包丁がないことはさすがに想定はしていなかったというのはありますんで
そんな状態だというのが改めて気づかされたんですけどそれであれ
防ぐはどうするかっていう話なんですね加工する技術が家庭になり
我々がやりたいことはプラットフォームをもう1回作り直すことなんだ
であればその加工の技術は誰が負担すべきか
それは氷店であろう
これってのあり方っていうのはれはもう一度探さなくちゃいけない
そう思ったんですね実際今東京都内で
魚の専門店氷店てそれがあるかって多分ご存知ないと思うんですけど
東京23区内でおそらく1000店舗ないんですね
ちょっと少ないかイメージがつきにくいかもしれないんですけど街の魚屋さん店が
ほとんどないんです
ほとんどないちょっと失礼なんですけど1000店舗くらい次回の23区内に存在して
ないんですね
それは量販店さんであったりとかスーパーの方から駆逐されてしまったという要素が
あるんですけどそれを我々はもう一度機能として作り直すなっちゃいけないんじゃない
かという事で今取り組んでいるのが差川の氷店をリアルいや
ています
なんで it なのに魚やるのリアル店舗やるのってよく言われるんですけど僕らは
実現したいビジョンにあたって重要な機能である氷な
それは当然やるべきだという感じでやっています
最後ですね実際やってみたことの一つ最後の3つ目なんですけど
水産をテーマにハッカソンを開催してみましたハッカソンわかりますかね
背後からですね
水産のハッカソンをやりましたこれはですねエンジニアの方を中心に現役の漁師さんに
も来ていただいてこのハチマキの方は船橋の漁師さんなんですけど
30名くらいの方に来ていただいて開催しました
おそらく私の知る限りでは
電気の予算と現役のプログラマエンジニアが同じ場に集って問題を共有しそこで解決策
を考えて頭ダクトを作り来るっていう事は恐らく史上初めてだったんじゃないかなと
思います
これを実行してみて会社にも大きな変化が起き始めるわけですね
a
ある方からは水産ハッカソンの第一汽車と言われ始めてあるけどまぁハッカソンやっ
てる水産ハッカソンなく私たちしかやってないわけなんですけど言われ始めたり
メディアから取り上げていただいたり
水産の専門誌の方からロン号開いてほしいって言われたいですね
論文は確かたの13年前で1回かいたぐらいしかないんですけど
その上で
霞が関の方から公園をしてほしいと言われるそんなことまで
を聞いましたこれは当初総計していなかった事です
私たちが本格的に仕事を開始してから昨年の10月ぐらいから動き始めてから今で
だいたい1年くらいだったんですけどその1年でとっても大きな変化があったなと思い
ます
当初私は一人で初めてお客も一人もいなくて
仕入先もなく知識も味といわしがギリギリわかるくらい
そんな上からスタートしてましたですが今で言うと
全国の産地のネットワークでパートナーが語熟語10カ所くらいあって飲食店は東京
中心に1000店舗ぐらいあって氷店もやって言って何よりも仲間が今25面
一緒にやっているところまで成長することができました
それはビジョンから目を離さないでとりあえず実行する
腰続けるそれを学び続けてきた結果ではないかなと思ってい
今日皆さんにお伝えしたいのは自分が精通している分野だったりとか
知識であったりとか経験にとらわれずに自分がこれをやりたいっていう分野があって
そこにもしビジョンが描けたのであれば
とりあえず実行してみるところから始めていいって学びの最高に入られたらどうかなと
いうことです
私が創業したときにですね色んな方から言われたも今でも思い出すんですけど
水産で知識も経験もないんだからうまくいくはずないんでやめとけど
いうことお客さんアブ方うかと言われました
その時にやっぱりすごく怖かったんですけど
その時に重要なビジョンをもう一回見直して自分が信じる10年後の
水産業界の姿というのを
自信を持って信じることができたかどうかなんですね
私はその時信じることができてそれに向かって恐怖に負けないで自分を com し
ながらですね
実行し続けてきたというのが今まで増えてきた
これたいうなんじゃないかなと思います
自分でですね実行することも実行しないことも選ぶことができてその結果の未来も
変えることができるということを学びました
私はこれからも
自分のビジョンを信じてそれに向かって熟考し続けていくっていうのをやっていきたい
とおもいます
皆さんのこれから一歩進めるにあたっての
何か良いアイディアに表なって言ってそれがお役に立てれば幸いです
どうもありがとうございましたはい